vamos a hacer un ejemplo un poco más
complicado acerca de sumar o bueno más
bien restar expresiones relacionales
vamos a poner un 4 14 entre 9 x cuadrada
menos 49 y pues de ahí vamos a restarle
vamos a restarle y lo van a poner en
otro color le vamos a restar un 1 entre
entre 3 13 x cuadrada más 5 x
- 28
entonces justo como elegimos en el vídeo
anterior queremos encontrar el mínimo
común múltiplo de estas dos expresiones
y para encontrarlo necesitamos para
actualizar estas dos frases para la
primera expresión de aquí se puede ver
como una diferencia de cuadrados es un
13 x cuadrada menos un 7 cuadrada
entonces voy a reescribir esto aquí
abajo como 4 como 4 entre a ver lo voy a
poner así le voy a poner como 3 x + 7 y
eso y de ahí hay que multiplicarlo por
un 3 x 7 y pues de ahí está 3 x al
cuadrado es 9 x cuadrado an 7 al
cuadrado es 49 entonces es una
diferencia de cuadrados de ahí queremos
representar el segundo término entonces
pues vamos a intentar factorizar lo
entonces esto de aquí pues tiene un
coeficiente que no es 1 al principio
podríamos usar la fórmula cuadrática
pero se va a poner muy facebook así que
no es recomendable la verdad lo mejor es
reagrupar entonces vamos a pasarnos por
acá mejor voy a hacer voy a hacer
espacios de este lado aquí a la derecha
creo que me voy a ir un poquito más a la
derecha entonces lo voy a escribir más
para acá
y tengamos un 3x cuadrado 5 x 28 y pues
queremos encontrar los números a y b
para que al multiplicar los verdad para
que multiplicarnos nos quede 3 x menos
28 haber es menos 60 menos 24 nos quedan
menos 84
multiplicando y además ve a más pues
debe ser igual al término del medio
entonces debe de ser igual a 5
entonces que en números podrían servir
pues claro 267 verdad ser bien sirven
muy bien entonces aquí ponemos un 12 y
si por acá ponemos un número 7
17 funciona porque 12 75 12 x menos 7 84
y entonces podemos escribir esto como 3x
cuadrada voy a poner el 12 por acá
verdad porque ya tenemos un 3 entonces
nos conviene más 12 x tenemos que restan
7 en que hay que restar el menos 28 y en
728 tiene un factor común así que pues
parece que todo va muy bien entonces
este 5x y simplemente lo único que se
puede partirlo en estos dos términos 12
656 menos 7 x 35 x y entonces ahora pues
ya podemos curvar
voy a ponerle paréntesis aquí para que
nos demos cuenta cómo estoy agrupando
aquí vamos a autorizar un 13 x entonces
voy a ponerle un 3x que me tengo que
multiplicar por x más 4
y pues el segundo que lo voy a marcar
con otro color lo voy a poner con blanco
esté aquí que estoy marcando con blanco
le voy a utilizar un -7 y hay que
multiplicar por x + 4 y hasta padre
porque ya tenemos otro x + 4 ahora
entonces vamos a poder factorizar los
dejen hacerlo aquí abajo lo voy a poner
aquí en este renglón entonces x + 4 y
hay que multiplicarlo por otras otras
cosas que quedan que son 13 x
al menos siete van entonces esta es la
forma en la cual existe este denominador
que el factor izado de describirlo por
acá entonces este segundo sumando es lo
mismo que
11 entre voy a poner primero el 3 x
menos 7 verdad 13 x menos 7 y hay que
poner multiplicarlo por x + 4 para
entonces ya está súper bolt súper bueno
verdad porque ya son lo mismo pero ya
están actualizados con eso ya podemos
seguir para encontrar el denominador
común entonces el nuevo el denominador
común verdad el nuevo que ya hacer pasar
la operación necesitaba los factores del
primer término un 13 x 7 y también
necesita un 3x menos 7 y también
necesita necesita los factores de
segundo entonces especial tienen 3x
menos 7 entonces pues este de aquí ya
están y pero el faltó un x más 4
entonces lo ponemos por aquí ponemos un
x más 4 y pues si nos damos cuenta este
es un múltiplo del primer denominador
y pues también va a ser un múltiplo de
del segundo denominador verdad porque
tiene también 3x menos 7 y un x + 4
vamos súper bien o sea ya tenemos el
mínimo común múltiplo ya nada más
tenemos que pues ahora obtener los
numeradores verdad pues ahora cómo le
hacemos para obtener los numeradores
porque tenemos que multiplicar el primer
término entonces pues nos falta lo único
que nos falta es un x + 4 lo voy a poner
aquí un poco a la izquierda aquí ponemos
un x + 4 y también tenemos que ponerlo
arriba no en x más cuatro verdad y
entonces el denominador ya funciona y en
el numerador pues en el numerador
también hay que multiplicarlo nos queda
4x más 16 y pues ahí está el primer
término del y del otro lado pues el del
otro lado ya tenemos ya tenemos algunos
factores verdad tenemos el 3 x menos 7
y el x4 pero el que nos falta es el 3 x
7 entonces pues tenemos que poner un 3 x
+ 7 lo ponemos abajo en el denominador
arriba para el numerador
y entonces tenemos 4 x + 16 - menos una
vez 13 x 7 entonces eso es lo mismo que
menos 13 x menos 7 simplemente
distribuimos el signo menos y ahora si
ya podemos hacer la operación verdad
ahora sí ya está padre simplemente
hacemos 4 x menos 13 x entonces nos
queda en total nada más una equis y
tenemos un 16 menos 7 nos queda un 9
entonces un entre hay que dividir hay
que dividir entre todo este rollo de acá
verdad que son 3 x + 7 también es un 3x
menos 7 y finalmente una x más 4 y listo